okay they're messy numbers but they're
just numbers so from here I can say the
axis R is equal to minus B on to a right
it's R because this is a quadratic in
our it's a lot of quadratic in X or
anything like that okay - b7 - plays a
double dated all divided by two lots of
this guy for pi plus PI squared cancel
36
what else can I cancel I can cancel some
pies right that sounds sad but in this
case of make things eat up kids for that
one
which means this one's gone and this
one's gone Chateauguay so this leads not
to weird what's on the top 36 what's
left on the bottom so okay what is this
new this is this the answer this is the
radius of this circle that's good but
have a look at the question reread the
question what are we actually asked to
find over the square so here is the
perimeter of the square I worked it out
earlier I just need to evaluate it for
this specific value of R so I'm going to
write that down I'll go over here
perimeter equals there it is 72 minus 2
times pi times this guy what have I got
4 plus pi right like that
third okay what I do with this this is
not so bad
lots of numbers but we can do with it
can't we 4 plus PI is the denominator
isn't it 4 plus PI as the denominator so
why don't I get this guy on the same
denominator which is 4 plus PI I think
that's going to be 28 that'll be 8 plus
72 pi that's on 4 plus PI isn't it -
what's that that's convenient isn't it
certainly smacks of a well-designed
question okay let's have a look at that
does that all check out yeah you saw
where this came from right it came from
the 72 cancel cancel and there is the
required perimeter okay now what's
challenging about this question I'll
admit there's a part of this question
that I don't like that's hard
which is just pies just lies you know
because it's irrational transcendental
it resists simplification so all the way
through you just have as medically
complicated stuff okay
but the real meat of the question is
actually all over here this is the real
question this is what's going on that
requires real mathematical skill that's
just calculation this is where you
really need to think about what the
question means and how to approach it
okay as I said before before I come to a
question Russell
I will leave it as an exercise to you to
define this let's let that be s all your
equations will be different now every
single one right because the area of
this thing will be s squared the
perimeter of this will be the perimeter
will be 4 s which makes the
circumference of this 72 minus that yeah
and then off you go you'd get different
equations ok
see if you get the same answer now see
you had a question before I come there
so I'm trying to find a maximum or
minimum right in this case it's a
minimum you can see when you have a look
at this guy here right
what kind of like is this concave up or
concave down concave up right so the
minimum is going to occur at the axis of
symmetry so I went straight to the axis
of symmetry that makes sense you have
three techniques for finding a maximum
or a minimum you factorize that gives
you the roots and you come halfway or
you can complete the square to find the
vertex right or you can go straight to
the axis
a tree which will tell you the exponent
or our coordinate in this case